There’s nothing wrong with getting a little sun -
it helps stimulate vitamin D production
and even helps us sleep better.
But too much time catching some rays
can earn you a nasty sunburn and increase your risk
of harmful conditions like skin cancer.
So how do you measure how much
UV-exposure you’re getting?
People typically use wearable devices
known as dosimeters to track how large of a dose
they’re getting of the sun’s ultraviolet rays.
But these devices have relied on straps
or clips attached to clothing, and rechargeable
battery packs, making them cumbersome
and susceptible to water damage.
Now researchers have developed a wireless,
battery-free dosimeter that can stick directly
to skin or fingernails, and measure exposure
to UV rays in real-time.
The chip is tiny, with a diameter around
half the size of a dime’s.
It uses a photodiode, a kind of semiconductor
that converts light into electricity, to not
only track how much light it’s been exposed
to,
but also to power the device.
The tiny chip also includes a sensor
to monitor the skin’s temperature, circuitry
to create a measurement of cumulative exposure,
and an antenna to wirelessly send the results
to the user’s smartphone.
To test the technology,
researchers had volunteers wear multiple chips
on different parts of their bodies while spending the day
participating in a variety of outdoor activities,
such as hiking and swimming.
They also wore a larger, traditional dosimeter for comparison.
While a few of the chips fell off
during the course of the experiment,
the ones that didn’t performed just as well
as the regular dosimeters,
and showed different parts of the body receive
different amounts of sunlight,
with the upper body absorbing the lion’s
share of ambient radiation.
The chips could one day be used
in medical applications -- the researchers also tested
their chips on the chests of infants
receiving therapeutic blue light treatment
for neonatal jaundice.
Using the chips to precisely monitor each
patient’s dose in real-time could lead to
tailored and potentially more effective light treatments.
These little “sun-chips” could also be used
in worker safety--tracking exposure to
UV rays for welders and steelworkers.
Researchers envision a future where these
handy dosimeters would be a part of everyone’s
daily wardrobe—stuck directly onto clothing,
sunglasses, or skin-—to let you know when
it’s time to stay off the sunny side of the street.